الاستثمار رياضيا في الابناء للصناعات
الثروه عشره الاف من اللاعبين المحترفين
حول العالم مكانه ليصلوا الى المجد لو
الاستثمار اهلهم فيهم فهم اثرياء والاهل
ايضا اصبحوا اثرياء اليوم من والد نيمار
الى والد ميسي واسرته الداعمه ووالده بابي
وكريستيانو رونالدو وغيرها كلهم راهن
واستثمر في الابناء فجلبوا لهم الملايين
اليوم
الاسره حول العالم الرياضيه
[موسيقى]
احنا دائما بنقول اللي طموحه القمر في
اسواق الحلال سوف يمسك بالنجوم بمعنى انه
العالم كله في 275 مليون لاعب كره قدم
منهم فقط 129 الف محترف يتقاضى رواتب
عاليه يعني زيرو
زيرو زيرو فور 7 المحترفين واللي بيستفيده
ماديا من كره القدم ولكن هذا لا يعني ابدا
ان لا يكون لديه طموح يعني لماذا لا يكون
ابني هو ميسي لماذا لا يكون ابني هو نيمار
فبالتالي باب الطموح مفتوح ومشروع بكل
تاكيد ولكن يجب على الاباء ان يتمتعوا
بدرجه من الوعي في التخطيط لابنائهم في
هذا الطريق والمساله فيها الكثير من
التفاصيل
راويه وبين الصناعه الكرويه هل يمكن ان
تتفوق الصناعه الكرويه على لاعب موهوب
بالفطره اصلا
المساله فعلا في فرق بين موهبه وصناعه اا
مش بالضروره يعني مثلا لو احنا بنتكلم عن
الرياضه بشكل مطلق او كره القدم كاحتراف
ومصدر للدخل للعائله وال- ولطفل اللي بعد
كده هيكون شاب او لاعب محترف لو بنتكلم عن
كره القدم تحديدا مش بالضروره كل عناصر
الفريق او التيم يكونوا موجودين يعني
دائما بنقول كره القدم هي تيمورك في شخص
موجود جدا ميسي في شخص فايتر مثلا خلينا
نقول اسمه في شخص حارس مرمى حسب الموهبه
وحسب القدر باختصار يستطيع الاهلي اكتشاف
همم ميول ابنهم لكره القدم وليس بالضروره
موهبه خارقه مش بالضرور يعني بعد كده ممكن
خضوع لمساله التدريب في اكاديميات وتدريب
في ليفل معين يصنع منه لاعب كره قدم جيد
وبرده باكد على المعلومه مش بالضروره كل
الاطفال اللي في العالم او كل من يريد ان
يلعب كره قدم سوف يكون مارادونا او ميسي
او رونالدو
[موسيقى]